Chris Evans has hung up his shield after
playing Captain America for nearly a
decade Chris took to Twitter on Thursday
revealing that he had wrapped shooting
on the upcoming untitled Avengers for
tweeting it was an emotional day to say
the least
playing this role over the last eight
years has been an honor to everyone in
front of the camera behind the camera
and in the audience thank you for the
memories eternally grateful they tell
you what we're up against
something about some psycho assassins
we're outside the law on this one so if
you come with us you're a wanted man
yeah well what else is now the 37 year
old actor first brought Steve Rogers to
life in 2011 while starring in Captain
America the First Avenger
how do you feel
Chris was back his cap in the 2012 film
The Avengers no offense but I don't play
well with others big man or soon armored
take that away what are you genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist and
Chris kept the hits coming starring in -
Captain America sequels and making
cameos as the superhero in a number of
other Marvel films first of all many
years ago when you took this job as
Captain America you said that you were
nervous about taking the job because you
know all these in 8 9 movies later
people are only gonna see one way now
you're one of the biggest movie stars in
the world was it the right decision it
was that wasn't exactly the the root of
the fear the fear was just the
commitment and and what would happen to
life the the the shift in you know
lifestyle you know the notoriety that
comes with movies like this and doing
movies one at a time you're afforded the
opportunity if you ever feel like doing
something else pursuing another average
and I another Avenue you you can you
know these giant commitments if you're
not responding well too bad because you
got another one coming looking back I
mean it's easily the best decision of my
life but all good things must come to an
end here's what he told et back in 2015
it's always feel so good to kind of wrap
and just say alright one more down you
know but but it's also kind of like high
school in a sense you know you keep
looking to when you're gonna be done but
then we're almost done now and you're
not quite ready for it to be over
it's almost terrifying to think about
these being done and while speaking with
et in March he revealed what he'll miss
most about playing cap I mean it's it's
not just the characters the people where
they experience such good movies
such wonderful memories miss a lot
[Music]